hey what's up guys my name is jonah
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we did some pretty exciting
stuff with gizmos we added gizmos
to the engine enough said check out that
video if you haven't already and today
we're going to be continuing on with the
fun
fun jamming in features without even
looking back stuff and we're going to be
adding in finally an editor camera
so what this is all about is at the
moment when we render our scene even
you know in the editor we actually have
to have a camera entity
if we don't have an entity in the scene
that is a camera or that has a camera
component on it
then we just won't even see anything and
furthermore we
even had some other issues where you try
it where if you try to select an object
and try and manipulate it using a gizmo
it will crash because there's no active
camera and the camera needs to be there
so we can even see the gizmo and
interact with it and all that stuff so
numerous problems but ultimately it just
comes down to the fact that we just
didn't have time to
jam in an edited camera it's a very
important concept because
obviously uh um and and also it just
becomes even more important when you
think about the distinction between the
actual editor and then the actual run
time
right because just like in any engine we
have like a play button we have a way to
actually play our scene
that's when we want to be using the
actual camera
entity but then when we're constructing
our scene of course we want to have our
own camera that has nothing to do with
the game
so that we can just observe the world
and manipulate it and
form it and do whatever we want with it
so that's what we're going to be
covering
today now a few few notes before we move
on with that um
first of all hazel is
uh hazel has no concept of runtime but
this is kind of oh thank you mid-dreamla
for subscribing welcome appreciate the
support um
oh we just got a little raid that's what
happened i was like what's going on with
all the
emojis anyway that's fun
hey watch your videos like every night
awesome mid-range thank you thank you
for reading
and uh anyway i'm in the middle of
recording a youtube video so let's get
on with that
um but uh yeah so where was i so yeah so
the the biggest problem with hazel right
now is we have we have no distinction
between runtime and editor but this is
kind of where
where we begin almost creating the
distinction so this is like one of those
historic moments that you mark um not
really but but basically as of today
we're going to actually split up
our our rendering functions inside our
scene class into
like a render editor and a render
runtime
and the render editor will ultimately
use the editor camera that we're going
to add and then
render runtime's going to use the
runtime entity um if it exists if it
doesn't we'll see a black screen
ultimately
so we're not going to like add the play
button or anything today but it is
going in that direction which is pretty
exciting because we're really seeing a
lot of
uh i guess growth you could say and uh
progress
in hazel um so how we're gonna do this
editor camera
now the other thing this is the other
thing that the other important thing
that i wanted to mention
um we uh at the moment our priority is
of course the 2d workflow
however even in a 2d game it's obviously
quite useful to be able to like orbit
around
and see our our 2d scene in 3d just
because it might help with picking
certain objects and just
moving around excuse me and
and moving around and doing all of that
stuff and if you just have like a 2d
camera
that's just tied to the two axes it
might be difficult so we are actually
going to be adding a 3d camera which is
pretty exciting
now it's very easy to lock the rotation
if you don't want it to rotate and if
you really do want the camera to just be
like
in 2d um we're not going to be talking
about orthographic projection for editor
camera here today
but as a perspective camera locking i'll
show you guys how to do that as well
and without further ado let's dive in
and take a look so
ultimately speaking um
[Music]
i've basically spent the whole morning
live streaming uh
and i figured out how to do all this
camera stuff i'm gonna be using my
camera class
from like five years ago i mean over the
last five years i've had like
i've developed this camera class and
i've been adding stuff to it and i
cleaned it up
this morning on stream as well so i'm
just going to copy and paste that in and
then i'll walk you guys through it it's
pretty simple it's mostly it's mostly
just a bunch of maths
um that you can probably study uh
yourselves
uh but it'll be you know part of hazel
from now on which is pretty cool
and and feel free to obviously use it
for um whatever you guys want to use it
for
um and there was one other thing that i
wanted to mention
uh oh yeah and we did some pretty fun
stuff this morning on stream
i streamed this by the way well you
probably saw with the whole rating thing
twitch or tv slash the channel is where
i live stream
um thank you guys a lot for your support
there's been a lot of people like
subscribing to me on stream and all that
stuff which is amazing
um and that really obviously helps me
you know deliver more and more content
to you guys which is amazing
but also like we did some pretty fun
stuff on stream this is what we did this
morning
so this is um this is also in a way a
good way to show you guys where hazel is
heading
this is hazeldev this is the patreon.com
version of
hazel that you guys can get access to if
you pledge um and support me on patreon
so um this is what hazeldev looks like
hazeldev
is exactly where hazel is going to so
this game engine series this is where
we're going right this is just my
version
that i've basically you know gone and
done my homework early in a way
and like you know um i've just done this
on my own time just to see
where we're going and how to implement
certain features because of course it's
getting harder and harder for me to just
write code off the top of my head
without spending hours like fixing it
and working out what the best ways to do
stuff and experimenting and all that
stuff
so this is ultimately where we're
heading um looks pretty cool
uh we've got some like
like a dancing storm troop and i'll
probably i'm sure more of this in like a
devlog a bit later on
but i thought it might be nice to um to
show you guys basically what the deal is
with uh hazel dev and everything that's
going on with that so
this is the kind of stuff that we work
on during the live stream um so if
you're interested in that
definitely go ahead and follow on
twitter tv slash the channel and also if
you want access to
the whole backlog of previous live
streams because you just can't get
enough of hazel content and you want to
learn more and you want to
see more then on patreon as well there's
like a huge backlog of
all the live streams i've basically ever
done so definitely take a look at that
okay without further ado um let's dive
in and take a look at how we can
actually get this editor camera here now
this it's already here
and that's because i forgot to revert
all the stuff that i did on stream to
test and to work out how to do
everything
so let me quickly that's awkward let me
quickly um
[Music]
i guess revert everything and this will
take us back to um
this will take us back to so it should
be gone now this will take us back to
the previous commit that we're at which
is on
git hub
having some coffee it's been a long day
oh no i did something terrible with yaml
okay so all right no worries just
remember the project file
so it got deleted because it's not
committed i just re-round pre-make and
we are good to go
this is where we left off last time okay
so we have this pink
cube this is what it looks like and we
of course added gizmos so that we can um
use them and actually see actually
manipulate everything
just using these on-screen gizmos
instead of relying on this transform
component ui over here
all of that is fantastic and great but
what about moving this
what about just being able to like alt
you know click and you know whatever to
orbit the camera around and actually
zoom in and out and pan around and
actually see everything working
what about all of that stuff how do i do
that stuff how are we even seeing this
first of all and how is the picking
stuff working
well i'm sorry i'm not not not the
picking but the uh
the gizmos so we have a camera at the
moment if we don't have a camera guess
what
we don't see anything we have these
entities in fact
and we get other crashes i think this is
because of
this we'll be fixing this as well today
it's because of the gizmo because the
gizmo expects that it'd be a camera
there's not a camera that's okay
it's just because we had we had an
active gizmo if we make sure we don't
have an active gizmo
and i delete this camera that's it you
know we have these entities they exist
in the scene
but where are they there's no camera to
actually render them we have to add
a camera which seems a bit ridiculous
because well you know
let's add a perspective camera like we
did last time let's you know pull it
back
or whatever and of course we can get
back to basically um you know where we
used to be
but the problem is that that's that's
not
how we want to do things we don't want
to be moving some kind of camera here
which actually is an entity in and of
itself we want we want to be able to use
an editor camera i don't think i need to
convince you guys that that's an
important thing but just in case
you're you you're new to this and you
might be like well why can't we just use
this camera
um because we want to basically observe
the world through the lens of like our
editor
and you know as a tool not necessarily
as a runtime
game because that's a separate thing
than an editor
um by itself okay so how do we
set that up well again what that means
is that we need to take a look at how we
render
things in the first place so if we go
over here into
our scene class we don't have a scene
renderer class i'll probably make that
in the future basically
i'm not going to talk about that now
actually because this episode is already
dragging on
but um for now everything happens inside
on update we update our scripts
we have our render 2d scene thing and
you can see that what we do here
is we look at look we basically look for
a camera so we look for
a camera component an scenario scene
that has a camera component
um and we check to make sure that it's
the primary camera and then if we find
it
then we have something to render so we
begin scene and we render everything
that's great for the runtime for the
editor that's not what we want to do at
all
now just to also put this into
perspective
there's no way that we want to update
scripts and actually run
our script runtime i mean this is just
like a native script thing it's just c
plus plus code it's not c
sharp yet but when we do have c sharp
scripts we don't want to run them during
the editor
right like when we're just observing um
everything through through the editor we
may want to execute certain scripts just
to see their effect but that's something
else entirely
usually we don't want to be running our
entities on update functions
during the actual just editor life right
it's it's when we hit play that we want
to start doing that kind of stuff
so because of that this doesn't even
need to exist anyway for the editor
right this was just here because we
needed a way to see our scripts running
and we don't have runtime so we just jam
them into the editor so all this is
wrong basically
what what this is leading towards is
basically me making something called on
update runtime
this is the runtime update function
ultimately and it always was it just
wasn't called that
so let's rename this to on update
runtime then i'm going to add another
function
called on update editor two code parts
some of them are going to be similar we
will consolidate a lot of them later
but you can also imagine that updating
the editor and updating the runtime
two very different things in fact we
might even want to split up the scene
class to be like
editor scene or like a scene renderer
for the editor or something like that
because obviously
the editor and the game two very
different things but for now
we won't go too crazy we'll just add
another function we'll call this one
during editor this one during runtime
right
pretty easy um but ultimately if you
think about it they
really are two different code paths
right like for example
in the editor we might want things like
gizmos like we might want like a grid
rendering we might want you know
outlines on the selected entity
none of that needs to exist inside the
runtime right we just render our meshes
um so it's very different basically my
point between the edit and the runtime
so one thing we'll add here as well that
we need is something called an editor
camera that's basically what we'll be at
what we'll be adding today because the
scene won't contain and edit the camera
but we're going to need some kind of
editor camera to be able to render
the scene through the editor's point of
view so we'll add that here
now what do we need from this function
well we don't need to look for the
camera
we don't need to update the scripts what
we need is just this basically
so it's actually really simple we just
need to do that um
now begin scene also doesn't take in
an editor camera we have this or the
graphic camera thing that's marked kind
of for removal
we basically need a version of this that
uses the editor camera so i'll copy and
paste this
um and we'll take in an editor camera
now i'm doing a lot of stuff here with
this
editor camera that doesn't exist yet
let's just jam it in and we'll see what
that looks like
so inside hazel renderer i will add
editor camera.h
it already exists ah i thought i deleted
it i guess it didn't revert properly
yeah it's here great i'll just include
it yeah that's easy
um it's even here that's oh because
premade picked it up
okay so this is the editor camera class
surprise
it just appeared out of nowhere um so
basically
so basically let's walk through this
class this is a class as i mentioned
that i've had for like
literally five years i remember when i
started sparky which is probably
in the beginning of 2015 so almost six
years i um
that's when i initially sat down and
wrote like a maya camera style
class so this is what it is right so
basically um
to be mostly brief because i think that
if you guys read the code you'll
probably understand it
i try to clean it up and write it in a
simple way um
basically to use this camera all you
need
and it actually extends well it's
actually a subclass of hazel's camera
which has a projection matrix
so all this does is it basically
controls like the view matrix right
so if you look at the update function
um if we press if we hold down alt
that's like the
so this is based on like the maya camera
i guess um so if you hold down alt
and then the middle mouse button it pans
so alt middle mouse drag
is pan um alt left mouse button drag is
rotate
um or orbit and then alt right mouse
button drag is zoom
you can also use a scroll wheel to zoom
as well so you can kind of read through
here and see what it does it calculates
the delta between how much the mouse has
moved
now there are a lot of little magic
numbers everywhere that's because over
time
this by the way i've been asked about
this before
i went onto like a graphing website and
i just plotted a graph and i worked out
just exactly what i wanted it to be like
and then i copied the
the function for the graph so you can
see that this is actually um
a quadratic function so we have like you
know
x squared minus x plus
you know whatever the constant is right
so
um that's how these numbers came about
they're not just random i actually
graphed it and i actually
spent a long time on this um probably a
couple years ago or a year ago just
tweaking it just so that it feels good
because you can see that the pan speed
is dependent on how big our viewport is
and you know there's some other things
feel free to change it this is just my
little
buttery smooth kind of camera class that
i like using
um which is obviously built on magic
so that's how it works um on mouse
scroll does a mouse zoom
we have mouse pan mouse rotate again
this stuff is um
fairly i guess simple we have like the
idea of a focal point we have your pitch
for our cameras
um we can't tilt the camera but we have
a urinal pitch so we have like a your
which is like our y
kind of axis rotation and pitch which is
our x-axis rotation
we have a distance that gets changed
based on when we zoom or not
so obviously zooming actually moves the
camera um and then we just have all of
these
uh kind of uh directional vectors based
on our orientation
so that we can apply the right pan and
stuff like that um so read through it um
it's mostly just a mathematical thing i
guess
and without doing a bunch of diagrams
and drawing everything it's going to be
difficult to explain with words
um but i think that it's i think that it
should be fairly simple
um you don't really it does use a little
bit of quaternions but mostly it's okay
um the quaternions are just really used
for i think
eventually calculating the view matrix
which happens over here
we just use translate and then you can
see that we get a uh
like a rotation matrix from that
quaternion over here now i added this
little comment in during the live stream
as well
that's to lock the camera's rotation and
we'll play around with both
sides of that as well um
yes stream i am recording okay
so um that looks pretty good
uh so that that's that's basically the
editor camera right so if we go back
into renderer 2d how do we
render with it well um there are some
convenience functions inside there
such as um get view matrix which is
really all we need
so begins in let's make a version of
that that takes in
um the editor camera so let's copy
everything
so what do we need we need the view
projection well luckily editor camera
has a function called get view
projection
literally all we need to do um right
that just gets the view projection and
then we pass it in and that's it
that is how we begin a scene with a
different view projection matrix done
right um and in scene
again we just take in camera
that's it so it's really simple nothing
much changes
we're just essentially at the end of the
day we're just sending a
different uh view matrix to our shader
right
so if we look at our shader that we're
rendering with which i think is called
like texture or something
shaders texture we have a view
projection matrix
that's the thing that's changing that's
it we're just sending a different view
projection matrix
because we're rendering through the
point of view of our camera our editor
camera rather than like some runtime
camera
that's the only difference this matrix
is different
um and then we just have to trace
everything back and obviously add some
you know controls i guess to edit a
camera which we do through
both events and also the update function
so really what we have to do is create
and edit a camera now inside the editor
layer
and then call on update every frame and
then call on event
when an event occurs and then if it if
it's like a mouse scroll event
then we need to deal with that actually
one more thing that we do need to do
that's really important
is the set viewport size function so we
need to set this function because if we
don't
then the aspect ratio of the perspective
projection is not going to be correct
so you need to set this whenever the
viewport changes and in fact you should
set it initially as well
you can provide an an initial aspect
ratio but because
that's probably at a point before we've
laid out our panels and we see how big
our viewport is it's probably going to
be
redundant like it's probably not
redundant but it's probably going to be
wrong
um so we need to actually provide our
own
we need to actually set the viewport
size once we know the viewport size
so how do we do this in editor layout
pretty simple let's just create a camera
so i'll just do it here edit the camera
m editor camera
editor camera let me just include that
as well so
include uh hazel renderer
editor camera dot h
it has a default constructor but we want
to create a slightly different one
the reason is that um when we first
created our camera with the camera
controller
um i think or rather sorry that doesn't
matter anymore the camera control would
probably get rid of that
when we first created the um camera
inside i think our i mean it's not going
to show up here but if i um
i can't really run this in that camera
let's go on update runtime for now
let's just run this see if everything
works still nope so scene.h is not happy
i think because we didn't include it
we may have included it in the cpp file
no we didn't
um
okay include that
include hazel first um we'll do run time
and then editor like that
just because runtime you could say is
more important
try to build that again
drinking the coffee is making me thirsty
so i'm drinking the water it's a vicious
cycle
all right we see everything right if we
look at the camera field of view is 30.
so we actually wanted a
slightly um lower i guess field of view
if you make it 45 it looks a bit
more distorted obviously and the more it
goes the more it goes
so um let's go ahead and set up a 30
degree field of view so that it looks
about the same
at least for this scene um so edit a
camera
if we wanted to do that we can always
change it later um so
30 field of view um again the aspect
ratio like who cares because we're gonna
resize it so
i'll just set it to 16 by nine it
doesn't matter i'll just do 1.78 or
whatever
um neoclip 0.1 file clip 1000
pretty reasonable values and then we
need to do everything to add a camera
that needs to be done
so um we need to update it so we'll do
edit a camera dot on update
do we need to do this if the viewport is
focused um
i guess so right i mean what does this
do it just does
yeah okay so we'll do that here
again we don't i'm not sure what's going
on with the camera controller i don't
think we need this anymore
but we'll we'll deal with that later
might have a maintenance episode when we
actually look at that because i don't
want to get distracted by a billion
other things and confuse you guys
so that's that right um we'll do on
update editor now
right so this should take in our editor
camera
when we do our viewport rendering that's
when we actually check to see if the
viewport size has changed
and that happens uh where does that
happen
viewport size being i think it happens
here actually
no that's docking enable and
where is the whole viewport size
view for panel size
huh i can't believe i lost this
there's definitely a there's definitely
a place where we um
check to make sure the viewport size is
changed well
we check to see if the viewport has
changed
and if it has it's up here it's a
non-update okay maybe
i'm not sure if it should be here but
anyway we do camera control on resize so
we do edit a camera set viewport
um and then this again gets set to these
two floats
if you bought size x and y um and then
finally the
the on event function needs to get
called as well so
we do that by doing edit a camera on
event
that is it and just like that just like
magic
we should now be able to have a viewport
camera
everything's very magical of these
episodes because i do all the hard work
on the stream
so if we create a new empty entity
starting with a new scene here right
i'm going to go ahead and add a sprite
renderer component to it
okay we don't see anything bad news
bears i know exactly why
well i don't know exactly why actually i
thought i knew why
but i guess not um so on update editor
should be getting seen with that
and we should have a view projection
matrix so actually that should have
probably
showed up because i think that by
default we should have pulled the camera
back a little bit
um and set it to
-10 which we did that's a bit odd
we should be okay we should have seen
something
oh i can kind of see it looks weird i
see dots
okay something's clearly wrong um
i wonder what we did wrong um so after
some stream debugging uh
we had our distance set inside the
position whereas we should have set it
here because position gets recalculated
so
everything was working it was just in
the wrong spot and it's obviously
difficult
if you have a camera that's like you
know somewhere in
like any correct spot like this it's
hard sometimes to find
your geometry because you have no idea
where it is
so instead of um you know because it's
still everything was here
it's just that it was we have to
actually zoom out
i think quite a bit to get
to this state and then we have
everything so instead of doing that
let's set the distance to 10 so that
we're kind of away
we're kind of focusing on the origin of
the scene but then we bring the camera
back
um so that we are 10 units away from the
focal distance
and that way you can see that we can see
everything immediately which is great so
we've added an empty entity
it's this and now we can do everything
so um
i'm using my mouse scroll wheel here my
mouse wheel to zoom in and out
if i hold down alt and the middle mouse
button i can pan
as you can see alt and left mouse button
is to orbit around
and alt right mouse button is same as
scroll wheel just to
scroll and just like in like a 3d
program i guess if you start getting
closer and closer
it'll actually slow slower and slower
because you have a
you have the concept of a focal point
and you can't go beyond the focal point
you can make the focal point jump
forward every time you cross it
that's super annoying in my experience
so if you actually want to move it
around
in the future there will be like an f to
focus button so that you can focus
but you can always just kind of pan on
the side like that um usually if you
want to move your
focal point to kind of move it this way
so that you can get closer to something
that's just a standard kind of 3d thing
with 3d programs usually and that's just
how the cameras usually work
all right let's try and open our um pink
cube scene our camera won't move by the
way it'll stay in the same place
there's our pink cube scene now as you
can see there it's a lie now we can
actually see that because we can orbit
around
um but ultimately uh yeah not not great
now what's going to happen if i try and
manipulate something with iron gizmo
well it's going to look stupid um it's
still going to work but it's going to
look really weird
why because obviously it's rendering
from the point of view of
this camera and additionally if we
didn't have that camera if i delete that
then if i try and manipulate something
it'll crash because now i can't find the
camera
so we need to add that back in how do we
do that
well it's pretty simple all we have to
do is find our i'm gizmo code which is
over here
and then instead of doing this camera
stuff so i'll call this runtime
camera which we get from the entity
i'll kind of comment this stuff out
because we will need it in the future
right and then i'm just going to add
like a little editor camera so this is
going to basically be the
same as that so i'll copy that
um just the difference is this is going
to come from editor camera
get projection and then this camera view
is going to be edit a camera
get view matrix okay that's
it um and then i think everything else
just remains the same
so let's hit f5 and hopefully now we'll
be able to orbit around like usual but
we'll also be able to
actually click on objects we'll not
click on objects but select objects in
the hierarchy
and move them around
okay so let's grab this
yeah and you can see that obviously now
the gizmos are all in the right place we
can move this
and you can see that we're really kind
of beginning to get like a little bit of
a 3d feel
here even though um this is still
technically
2d well the thing is it was always 3d so
when i say things like it was tool to
be 2d i mean our goals are still
technically 2d but
this obviously is quite 3d um because
that's just the way opengl works
um everything is 3d um let's maybe dim
the lights a bit
and we kind of have a nice background
now in 3d space obviously
and you can see that it's probably quite
easy to just keep adding stuff like this
maybe
rotate it um 90 degrees or something
like that
make it way bigger now we have like a
little ground plane and you can see that
we're
practically already like half of the way
to this
so in no time you know in no time um
you will see uh this inside hazel
okay anyway um that's gonna wrap up the
stream
and uh the episode hope you guys enjoyed
where is all my stuff i actually have a
i got a stream deck now so i can use
that fancy but thank you guys for
watching if you enjoyed this video
please don't forget to hit the like
button if you're watching on twitch
don't forget to
follow and maybe even subscribe if
you're feeling generous um
don't forget that you can help support
this series and everything that i'm
doing with hazel over at patreon.com
huge thank you to everyone who does help
support
me and everything like that astro thank
you so much for subscribing
there you go see people already taking
the initiative it's brilliant
i would not be here without your guys
support so i really truly do appreciate
this because obviously working on hazel
um as like a full-time thing is is
basically a dream job so
thank you guys so much um and if you do
help support on patreon you'll get
access to all of that
hazel dev code that i mentioned with
that animation stuff and uh
you know all the 3d rendering and
basically you can probably make a little
game there because it's got a sharp
scripting and everything so if you want
to take a peek at where the game manager
series is heading definitely help
support that and you also get access to
all the live streams
all the um recorded live streams and
stuff like that
but thank you guys for watching um and
uh next time
uh i think it's probably a good idea to
work on textures
because we're seeing a lot of kind of
flat colored stuff and that's great but
i want to be able to see textures
maybe mouse picking is something that
you know being able to click on an
object and actually pick it in the scene
that would be useful
um and we could definitely set that up
uh
and also oh actually i forgot to show
one thing sorry guys i bought mission we
are going back
we are going back so what i wanted to
show um
was the locking thing right so if you
want to lock the camera because you
you know you you really do want it to be
2d in a way like
the camera itself i mean so if you um
open this up
upside of the camera let's add a sprite
renderer
um if you just want it to be kind of i
already ruined it
i pressed a helder button that i
shouldn't have held um
so if we go to sprite renderer if you
just want it to be
uh see this is annoying this is what i
mean by the viewport focus thing this
doesn't work until i click and then i
can do it so
i don't want that to happen let's go to
the whole
viewport focus thing because apparently
middle mouse click doesn't focus the
viewport
so let's go ahead and quickly revert
that um or like not revert it but
just do that and i'm not sure about the
camera controller that's just weird
um yeah we're going back
um so uh yeah if i create an empty
entity again and this time it should
work yep
um so if you just want this to exist
right and you don't want
this rotation because it's kind of 2d
then all you have to do and we might
expose this later as like a check
option thing or whatever but basically
all you have to do is set
the your and pitch to just zero before
we do the
before we update the view right that
will just get rid of any rotation
um it'll set everything to zero and that
way
if you um you know add this back in then
you just won't be able to so i'm
pressing alt and left click here nothing
is happening right
so everything will just be fixed to this
um so you can keep it like that if you
want
and obviously all the gizmos and
everything will work and you can rotate
it because it is obviously still in 3d
but you just won't be able to move the
camera past that it's always going to be
fixed
kind of um in like a 2d view you could
say with basically no
rotation um and no tilt either because
that's weird
but i guess you could add something for
tilt if you really wanted to so i will
leave that unchecked just because i
think it might be cool for people to
obviously explore
all the stuff we've done today in like a
3d fashion
um but ultimately uh this is what it
should look like
if you actually um open up the
repository and take a look for
yourself so thank you guys for watching
hope you enjoyed the video as i said
before
and i will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you